una fórmula para alcanzar la paz fue la
base de la intervención del presidente
ucraniano golovémir zelenski ante la
asamblea general de la ONU el único
discurso a distancia debido a la guerra
que atraviesa su país el primer paso
castigar a Moscú eliminar el derecho al
voto y el veto en el Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU la creación de un
tribunal especial y sanciones a los
propios ciudadanos rusos fueron algunos
de los puntos enumerados por el líder
ucraniano
Ucrania exige un castigo porque se
intente robar nuestro territorio castigo
por el asesinato de miles de personas
castigo por las catastróficas
turbulencias que Rusia provocó con su
guerra ilegal y no solo para nosotros
los ucranianos sino para todo el mundo
el segundo punto asegurar el derecho a
la vida selenski condenó a los
asesinatos masivos y recordó las fosas
encontradas en bucha eysium y aseguró
que para que exista Paz los estados
deben poder cuidar a sus ciudadanos un
objetivo que solo se puede lograr según
señaló con ayuda internacional
si necesitan ayuda financiera para ello
Hay que darles ayuda financiera si para
lograr esto es necesario ofrecer datos
de inteligencia háganlo pero lo que no
necesitamos son mentiras
el hambre en múltiples países del mundo
el uso de la energía con fines políticos
por parte de Rusia y el peligro de un
desastre nuclear ilustraron el tercer
elemento resaltado por celenski la
restauración de la seguridad y la
integridad territorial unas acciones que
llevaron a catalogar a Rusia como
patrocinador del terrorismo
un estatus que dijo deberían adoptar los
países garantes de la paz
Cuando un país trata de robarle el
territorio a otro estado está atacando a
todas las naciones del mundo la
seguridad internacional no se puede
restablecer Si no se restablece la
integridad territorial de la nación que
ha sufrido la agresión Armada
la cuarta medida las garantías de
seguridad para protegerlas selenski
resaltó la necesidad de tratados
multilaterales y bilaterales y también
de mejorar la arquitectura de seguridad
de Ucrania para evitar nuevas agresiones
la determinación fue el último punto de
su intervención una que señaló una todos
los elementos así concluyó con un
llamado al trabajo conjunto del mundo
hacia la paz